chandler jones done for the season with
a biceps injury confirmed yesterday 61
sacks over the last five seasons most in
the national football league
bad news for the cardinals who are
getting ready to face the cowboys this
weekend they're three and two after
losing a couple of games following the
2-0 start chris how much does this
injury hurt the cardinals for the
balance of the year oh well it's it's
huge i mean chandler jones is he's a
hell of a football player i mean we've
he's one of those guys i think he's one
of the most underrated players in the
sport and for the way arizona wants to
play right when you see them win
football games they usually jump out to
an early lead and they kind of force you
into a game where yeah we're throwing
the ball in all these things and now we
got a lead and you got to throw the ball
a little bit too and he tees off he's by
f he's the best player on their defense
you know him and buddha baker so now
they don't have either one right now
buddha baker's banged up two but jones
yeah i mean he is their best front seven
player their best pass rusher uh i feel
for him and i know he's the kind of guy
just you know being in new england with
chandler a little bit you know his his
brother ufc his other brother defensive
lineman for the ravens and the cult it's
like they're as tough as it comes as far
as that family's concerned and i know he
exhausted all options trying to figure
out how to not get surgery unfortunately
yeah it's going to hurt their team
yeah and look the cardinals offensively
that's the focus but yeah but but the
deep the defense
needs to be better it has gotten a
little bit better here they are three
and two and third place in the toughest
division or one of the toughest
divisions in football you know shireen
williams and i were talking about this
the other day and somebody raised this
question on pftpm which division is
better right now the nfc west or the afc
north oh
i think right now
i
i'd probably go with the afc north right
now just
because i don't know where the you know
the cardinals and the 49ers i think are
very iffy right now
you know the cardinals are kind of in a
lull again i know they won last week but
it was 1710 in the fourth quarter
against the crappy jets it wasn't like
oh wow they blew them out yeah and then
49ers were banged up and now the
emergence of cleveland and the afc north
i'm going to give them the edge right
now
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports